hi my name is Caitlyn Boos I am a data
scientist and I'm so excited to be here
today to speak to you all about what I
wish I knew before becoming a data
scientist so as a scientist I tend to
hypothesize on many aspects of my life
including what my career might look
like so I'm about three years into my
career now and my expected trajectory
looks vastly different from the reality
of my
career so here was my misconception
about what my career might look like and
opposed to the reality So within my
experiences of being a tutor intern
subject matter expert consultant mentor
and scientist I've definitely learned a
lot of lessons along the way of course
some of which are technical lessons like
what would have saved me hours of
debugging or what packages I should have
loaded in sooner but that's not what
this talk is about today though I'll
give an honorable mention to Docker fer
because imagine me trying to create a
Docker file from scratch for 12 hours on
a Sunday this talk is really about the
human lessons that I've learned
navigating my career for the first time
and in sharing these lessons with you I
hope that no matter what role you may
hold now or what stage of career that
you're in you can resonate with some of
these lessons or if you're an aspiring
Tech professional you can take these
lessons as a heads up
so the first thing I learned is that
success is not linear second I learned
the importance of exploring but also
finding your focus and thirdly I learned
to count on community so diving into the
first one success is not linear so
here's a plot of my perceived successes
and failures three years into my
career and if we look at this line of
best fit we can see that it was not an
upward trajectory and that there were
several Peaks and vales that I
experienced so why shouldn't we always
expect an upward trajectory well there
are several different factors that
change over time such as external
factors such as shifting role
responsibilities emerging industry
Trends or changing economic conditions
and there's also changing internal
factors like maybe you create new goals
for yourself your interests change or
develop maybe your priori
shift so given these changes it's
inevitable that they can also bring
about challenges and some of which
challenges won't always catapult you
upward so I just recommend embracing
your perceived failures knowing that
there's going to be a success around the
corner next explore and find your focus
as a professional you need to choose a
role industry and then the different
tools and Technologies you're going to
use to be successful in that
role so this is an overview of what just
a data science landscape may look look
like there's so many different roles
Associated to being a data science
professional several different
Industries you can work in and so many
tools and technologies that you're
likely to encounter throughout some
points of your career so given the vast
number of roles Industries and tools and
Technologies there's approximately 32
million combinations of choices that
you're faced with considering one role
one industry in about three tools and
Technologies so to deal with all of
these choices I highly recommend finding
your focus so start on something but
don't forget to explore since there are
so many different directions you can go
and manyi skills which are also
transferable that can help you go from
one role to another or one industry to
another thirdly count on community I'm
personally a part of different women in
Tech communities and different data
science communities and throughout my
engag engagements with these communities
I've developed a great sense of purpose
solely by just showing up next I've
gained a great sense of connectedness by
being able to relate to the individuals
a part of these communities I think
you'd be surprised how many people share
similar stories and experiences to
yourself next I've gained a great sense
of inspiration just being surrounded by
like-minded humble and Incredibly
talented individuals in the tech
industry doing some really cool things I
want to give an honorable mention again
to data science hangout this is where
I've developed my core community and I
think we've been very helpful to each
other throughout all of our careers so
in summary by embracing a nonlinear
career path finding your focus through
exploration and leveraging the community
I hope that these lessons help you
thrive in your Tech Career so thank you
so much feel free to check out my
website connect with me on LinkedIn if
you want to create your own career
reflection plot um the code is on GitHub
for that so thank you so much and I hope
you
[Applause]
enjoy